The bloopers from the Avengers films might
be some of the funniest we've seen in a while.
In fact, they're so funny that it's hard not
to fall in love with the films all over again.
Not so tough props
In the realm of superheroes, especially Norse
mythology-derived superheroes, you're only
as good as your accessories.
Thor has quite a few: his long red cape, his
long blond hair, and his mighty hammer Mjolnir.
When it comes to his hammer, it's so tough
and unbreakable that it took the might of
Hela, the goddess of death, to finally break
it in Thor: Ragnarok.
Maybe they got the idea for that moment from
this blooper in which Thor's magical hammer
sure seems like a very breakable prop.
One of the few things as iconic as Thor's
hammer in the MCU is Captain America's shield.
It's about as classic as superhero equipment
gets and it's so powerful that Cap routinely
busts through walls and locks with it.
Unfortunately, the real prop shield they use
in the filming is a lot less useful than its
fictional counterpart.
Vocal flubs
It's easy for the comic book version of Bruce
Banner to just rattle off scientific terms
because someone can just scribble them into
a speech bubble.
It's clearly a bit harder for actors to say
all those complicated words in real life.
Just watch Mark Ruffalo as he struggles to
deliver what's clearly a mouthful of technical
mumbo-jumbo in The Avengers: Age of Ultron.
In a deleted scene in Iron Man 3, Trevor Slattery
successfully passes himself off as a Russian
over the phone, which leads to Colonel James
Rhodes asking him to try out a number of other
voices.
It's really just a chance for Academy Award-winning
actor Sir Ben Kingsley to display his acting
ability and dialect talent — because he
can handle every suggestion actor Don Cheadle
throws his way.
“Jamaican”
“I come from Jamaica.”
“Can you do French?”
“Allo, je suis Francais.”
“Can you do like, a Spanish.”
“I can do, but…”
“Shut up!’
Well, almost every suggestion.
“Can you do British?"
"Well, I am British."
Hulk run away!
When Bruce Banner turns into the Hulk to punch
a giant alien in The Avengers, it's a stand-up-and-clap
moment.
However, as it turns out, that wasn't exactly
the first instinct that actor Mark Ruffalo
had when facing down a CGI monstrosity.
“Dudes, you’re on your own!”
Considering how terrifying the aliens looked
on the big screen, it's hard to fault Ruffalo's
acting instincts.
Short-circuiting Vision
Paul Bettany used to just provide the voice
of JARVIS in the Marvel Cinematic Universe,
but these days he's using his whole self to
play Vision.
Bettany is barely recognizable under all that
red makeup.
While he certainly looks the part of the super-advanced
robot, he's acting more like a malfunctioning
computer in this blooper from Captain America:
Civil War:
Not so serious
One of the most impressive things about the
MCU is that the actors are able to take it
all seriously when surrounded by goofy costumes
and CGI monsters.
It's the kind of true commitment to character
that explains why they get paid so much.
However, that doesn't mean there aren't a
few moments where that seriousness cuts out.
In this lineup of stern, determined-looking
heroes for Avengers: Infinity War, Benedict
Wong just couldn't keep the steely resolve
on his face for more than a few seconds.
Captain America's hot tip
Spider-Man: Homecoming included one of the
most memorable cameos in MCU history when
Chris Evans' Captain America pops in via green-screened
video to deliver some corny, educational advice
to the students of Peter's high school.
"So.
You got detention.
You screwed up."
However, one particular video is just a bit
too over the top for Evans to make it through
without cracking up.
"Hi, I'm Captain America.
Whether you're a student or a soldier, there's
one thing that will always give you an edge:
A hot lunch."
Room to vroom
Ant-Man and the Wasp was packed with plenty
of car chases through San Francisco, a city
full of steep hills, big curves, and tons
of traffic.
In this blooper, Paul Rudd gets into character
as he prepares to shoot one of those sequences:
“Good scene, everyone, let’s have lunch.”
“Best scene in the movie!”
“Is it bad if I start saying this, ‘Vroom
vroom, vroom vroom vroom!’”
Stan the Man
An MCU movie made in the last few years just
wouldn't be complete without a Stan Lee appearance,
and Ant-Man and the Wasp had one of the legendary
creator's best cameos.
As Scott Lang, Hope Van Dyne, and their associates
battle bad guys through the twisty streets
of San Francisco, Lee shows up as a guy whose
car gets shrunk by Ant-Man's signature technology:
"Well, the '60s were fun, but now I'm paying
for it."
It turns out that's just the take filmmakers
decided on; they had Lee go through a huge
list of funny possibilities.
"Aw no, my sandwich was in there!"
"Well, at least now I'll be able to park in
San Francisco."
Great job, Heidecker!
The two Ant-Man movies are pretty much the
funniest of all the MCU standalone flicks.
The casts of both feature performers with
a knack for comedy, including Walton Goggins,
Michael Peña, Randall Park, and Judy Greer.
Even so, it's a pleasant surprise for viewers
to suddenly encounter Tim Heidecker, a comedy
innovator known for his bizarre, boundary-pushing
work on cult TV favorites like Tim and Eric
Awesome Show, Great Job!
In Ant-Man and the Wasp, he plays the leader
of a San Francisco Bay boat tour guide.
Some of Heidecker's best lines were unfortunately
left for the blooper reel though.
“I freak for whales.
I've loved them ever since I was a kid.
I'm not trained really, or know anything about
biology.
I've memorized some things, but I couldn't
go deep.
Did you say Wakanda?
Black Panther is a crowning achievement in
filmmaking, and it also gave the world one
of the all-time great movie catchphrases.
It even makes an appearance in Avengers: Infinity
War.:
"Wakanda forever!"
Since Black Panther's release in early 2018,
millions have flashed each other the crossed-arms
salute.
By now, everyone knows how to say "Wakanda"
correctly, but during the film's production,
a few cast members had trouble getting it
down.
In this clip, neither Martin Freeman or Danai
Gurira are confident in their ability.
“The thing that was on your arm?
Is from Wakanda?”
“Wakanda will neve ----BLEEP!”
Doctor of dance
Doctor Strange was a harder sell than your
typical superhero movie.
After all, Doctor Stephen Strange's powers
come from an ability to connect with the worlds
of mysticism and magic.
To effectively ground that in reality, the
filmmakers required the services of actor
with extensive classical training and an impressive
résumé full of award-winning dramatic roles.
That actor: Benedict Cumberbatch, who earned
widespread acclaim for his work in Sherlock
and The Imitation Game.
But who knew that Cumberbatch could be so
silly?
Underneath all the pomp and circumstance,
he's just as goofy on set as a wacky comic
actor.
Judging from this blooper reel, he's especially
down to get down, breaking into dance routines
while filming his scenes.
It's apparently contagious, because most of
his co-stars got in on the dance craze, too.
Asgard's funniest home videos
One of television's longest-running hits is
America's Funniest Home Videos.
Debuting in 1990, this long-running series
has delighted the masses with miles of poorly-shot
and grainy footage of grown men getting hit
in the private parts.
The MCU movies, for all their big-budget set
pieces, aren't immune to that simple joy getting
included on the blooper reel.
"Did I hit your testicle?"
"I'm fine."
Comedy Gold(blum)
In the '80s and '90s, Jeff Goldblum brought
a disarming charm and off-center sensibility
to his roles in otherwise straightforward
movies like Jurassic Park and Independence
Day.
In doing so, he made them much better than
they otherwise could've been without him.
It makes sense then that when director Taika
Waititi took the Thor movies in a cosmic and
comedic direction with Thor: Ragnarok, he
brought Goldblum in for a role.
Goldblum plays the Grandmaster, the most hedonistic
of all the Elders of the Universe.
The actor brings his trademark looseness and
an almost jazz-like approach to the movie,
which is noticeable even when he's goofing
off between takes.
“Watch this.”
"Loki, take it away."
The cape can't cope
Thor's wardrobe is about as eye-catching as
the lightning that often accompanies the character.
In addition to Chris Hemsworth's own indisputable
good looks, Thor usually rocks a tight metal
shirt, rad pants, and one undeniably great
cape.
But while the accessory might be stylish,
it can be pretty temperamental.
On the set of Thor: The Dark World, Hemsworth
tries his best to act, but he has trouble
due to an unpredictable co-star: His cape.
Iron Man can't suit up
Science fiction films and superhero movies
are full of mythology, backstory, and their
own sets of rules.
Iron Man 3 is a sci-fi film as well as a superhero
movie, and it's got a lot specific words and
jargon its actors need to clearly and slowly
deliver so the action around them makes sense.
It's a delicate balance to nail the terminology
that's been part of a comic or cinematic universe
for years so it satisfies both hardcore and
new fans alike.
That's why Marvel and its filmmakers hire
top-notch talent to deliver the written lines.
Actors like Robert Downey Jr. have the training,
skill, and talent necessary to say all that
technical talk in a believable way.
Still, sometimes it's hard to get those words
out, because even for an actor of Downey's
caliber, there's a lot to remember.
In Iron Man 3, Tony Stark has to recall his
various super-suits.
There are a lot of them, and in this blooper,
Downey Jr. needs the assistance of the Heartbreaker
armor to help out the armor whose… name
escapes him.
"Heartbreaker, will you help… what's his
name?
Red snapper?"
Wild, wild goat
While the MCU movies enjoy a lot of cast overlap
for their various superheroic characters,
Black Panther came out of nowhere to introduce
many fantastic characters to the Marvel Cinematic
Universe.
It also had the added benefit of making huge
stars out of the actors and actresses who
portrayed them.
Chadwick Boseman had attained some fame after
playing Jackie Robinson and James Brown in
42 and Get On Up, respectively, while Lupita
Nyong'o achieved her breakthrough with 12
Years a Slave.
Now they're A-listers thanks to their roles
at the top of the cast of this superhero action
blockbuster.
Danai Gurira established a big-screen career
for herself beyond her role as the katana-wielding
Michonne on The Walking Dead, but in this
blooper, she's quickly and effectively upstaged
by yet another breakout MCU star: a goat.
Check out one of our newest videos right here!
Plus, even more Looper videos about your favorite
stuff are coming soon.
Subscribe to our YouTube channel and hit the
bell so you don't miss a single one.